all right uh
let's briefly look at this one which is
the last one on the page um
i've just put some notes on here just
have a look at my colors you didn't have
to use colors you didn't have to
but just like underlining parts of the
question that are important if you used
colors it was a lot easier to do the
question can you see i've highlighted
one of the lines in blue
that's a b
and then i've rotated just that one by
the
270 degrees you see that and so now you
can see i've got a new blue line this
guy over here right in the same way i've
got a red line and i rotate that one
around and that will give you the shape
that you need okay
all right so now i'd like you to turn
over
actually a couple of times
go all the way to page six
we did well for the rest of geometry so
i just want to make a couple of comments
on decimals
first number two
some people saw number two which is
round
and what they wrote was this 0.34293
times 100
is 34.2
now there's a an issue of confusion
there right this is not about
multiplication don't change the number
just tell me what this number is with
only two decimal places of accuracy so
you had to look and see okay this 2
does that mean i round the 4 up or down
down or rather it stays put ok so that's
why 0.34 is the answer so just be
careful read the question see what it's
asking you uh part b was interesting
write a number that's between 14.5
and
14.49
yeah some people said there's the number
between 14.5 and 14.49 and there is
there's always a number between any pair
of numbers you pick you could picked up
you could have picked a whole bunch of
different ones uh probably an easy way
was just to say uh 14.49
how much do you have to add to it to get
to 14.5 think carefully how much do you
add to move up yeah
0.01 so if i added
0.01 it would get to 14.5 so all i need
to do is just add something that's a
little bit smaller like maybe
0.001
that's smaller isn't it and if i add
that instead
it's just going to be that number do you
see that number is bigger than 14.49 but
i haven't got all the way up to 14.5 or
you could have added a 2
or 3 or
105 whatever you like okay it would have
been fine
whoops
okay um i think
only the last question is worth
commenting so go to the last page now
and then from there
we've got 20 minutes to um
finish going through that writing your
own comments or corrections and then
i'll let you work on the rest of the
time maybe on the chapter revision
chapter review for decimals last
question read it with me
helen is making a tablecloth out of
material that costs that amount per
meter she needs 2.3 meters calculate the
total cost of the material now
interestingly uh if you just you don't
have to look back at this but just
remember this question over here
two and three
if you have to round off right if you
have to round off usually you will be
told please round to this number of
decimal places or that number of decimal
places but you'll notice this last
question doesn't tell you to round off
to any number of decimal places in
particular
that's because you're expected to know
there's a clue in the question that
tells you how many decimal places you
should round off to
right money is the key thing it's
dollars and cents yeah which is the key
word which is the key word okay
so maybe you want to make a note
for question seven in decimals oh i
didn't recognize money should be two
decimal places